I was gonna do the podcast standing up
for old times but I thought I'd sit down
be in frame and show off this super dope
sweater yeah super dope
super dope guess what color it is maroon
touch it don't development oh very nice
just like King Joffe Joe furs lion skin
in it coming to America is that his name
I think you're trying to say King
Joffrey from Gaiman oh I don't even
watch Game of Thrones no no raping and
pillaging I don't watch that one listen
I don't know who you are anymore
I'm Kristin cuz it's 2019 yeah you would
reinventing yourself this weird yeah new
year new Sims that's what everybody does
is that right new year new Sims get a
new diet go to wear new clothes
we don't do new we don't do new we're
constantly working on new we just add
things we'd like to improve I mean if
you're just sitting back content with
self then you're missing out on life I
could just die so let me ask you this
what do you have a new year's resolution
nope now that I can think of I'll tell
you one thing that I probably need to be
better at I getting to be better at not
stressing about my job so much and
enjoying it like you've heard me say
before I also need to work be better at
kind of contacting people who I'm
friends with and staying in contact with
them but not like they're not like a
media in the front like I'm very bad at
like I'm awful I know like we you know
we were good friends three years ago
when I was in Boston living in Boston
and I've moved away from Boston it'll be
texts from time to time but we haven't
talked in two years you wanna know how I
handle this oh wow is there a
spreadsheet involved it's not a
spreadsheet but it does involve Google I
have a list of people who are exactly
what you're describing people that were
I was close to at one point in life but
now based on whatever I'm not and you
keep it running schedule no I have a
Google Calendar event it's recurring
once a month and all of their names are
in there and then every once a month I
get an email from Google with all their
names and I just pick a couple of them
and send em text that's good for you
yeah that's a good reminds me every
month yeah I know what I go through this
I feel the same thing I feel bad and
then I go well crap why aren't they
texted me and then I feel great again
yeah I know but sometimes that people
text me and I still don't text them back
that's what I'm bad at like I'm like oh
I'll text him later and then I got 90
text messages from Bleacher Report and
NBC and a few coaches and whatever else
and then I forget to text them at the
end of the day then all sudden it's a
week two weeks and I go through my phone
when you're home yeah and then I'm
embarrass and I'm like oh alright look
it up and I go oh damn I forgot the text
you know what the problem is yeah
iMessage on the iPhone
you can't leave a text mark as unread
you're right you can't go bad is it
really annoying yeah I agree yeah I
agree
so if there's an Instagram you can leave
Instagram DMS unread so that's the
reminder for us when we're answering all
the left go back and go to the unread
one yeah you know what I'm gonna
spontaneously go through some of the DMS
at the end of today's show we are gonna
be saving most of our playoff break down
for the betting podcast for games $1600
one champion one leader in the clubhouse
right now thy name is Christopher David
Simms you can't just say thou no but we
figure we're gonna do the same amount of
time we always do but we're gonna go
super heavy on the four games so today's
gonna be more what's going on in the in
the sports world we're gonna have Phil
Simms on as always we'll get we'll get
Phil's what do you think his playoff
expectations are yeah let's hear him
talk about it a little bit yeah and at
the end that's right the SL FL champion
grand champion excuse me grand
first-ever out of three hundred and
ninety two teams Enrique Vasquez what
does no California is gonna come on and
do five minutes way to go Enrique you
the man he dot vida yeah pretty excited
that's cool the clear D beat in the
finals you know he was competing against
team all 21:28 champions competed in one
big week and I think he kind of smoked
everybody read twenty thirty points Wow
yeah his his final roster right for that
week was deshaun Watson say Quan picked
up Damien Williams who had a huge week
Robert Woods a big game against San
Francisco and Robbie Anderson Zach Ertz
Jamal Williams the Dolphins and Justin
Tucker
for the year I would not think that's
the championship team but it was for
Enrique yeah that's pretty good though
yeah it's a lot of guys there that's
fantasies only offensive guys yeah he
hit the right guys for this week Oh
Antonio Brown Antonio Brown if the
2018-19 season has been one thing it has
really tied up a lot of the loose ends
of the Simpson Lefko storyline right
Odell got his contract we had clamored
for years
Aaron Rodgers got his contract we
clamored for years everyone [ __ ] Mike
McCarthy saw his end the the good
offense has kind of rose to the top the
Mensch George Kittel all these little 70
numbers Blake bortles oh how could I
miss that one the truth finally came out
there but we have been saying for 2 to 3
years that all of the harmful things
they hurl at Odell right should have
been focused in Antonio Brown really
this entire time you've actually talked
to a lot of people I have and me and
Josh came in here today and looked at
each other and said he's been talking to
Tomlin and then we learned you have not
I am not know these are things rare put
on your shefter hat ok me and Josh are
gonna rate you from 1 to 10 ok I'm now
gonna toss it over to our embedded
reporter Chris Simms team insider team
insider Chris Simms what's going what
happened with Antonio Brown the Steelers
we'll see here's the thing left go ok I
just understand it sounds like that's so
they always gray palette that was very
sad yeah yeah then you have to hold up a
newspaper yeah I mean it is funny and
it's we have talked about that so much
whether we've talked about how Odell
gets criticized like greatly for some
things than Antonio Brown could do the
same thing or something worse and it
kind of flies under the radar but yeah
when this all happened and went down I
started to get some Inklings and yeah I
have connections with people in
Pittsburgh right you know it's not just
Pittsburgh but I have a lot of people ex
players players people that are in the
organization now
and you know when I first heard the
stories I kind of just yet reached out
to a few people just to kind of get a
feel cuz I had heard a few things also
from other NFL insiders to where I was
like oh okay like damn did that really
happened and then I was like started to
text the people that I knew would know
all right right give me your first juicy
nuggets
my first you found juicy well my first
juicy nugget would be that just you know
he didn't throw the ball back at Ben
like that like what what happened was
from my understanding they were doing a
walkthrough Antonio missed his hot route
during they blitz he was supposed to
turn around and be the hot route he
didn't do it so my understanding is that
Big Ben and the OSI kind of said oh
let's do it again and Big Ben was
walking back to the huddle and Antonio
felt disrespected like he didn't need to
redo that like he knows what he's
supposed to do and he was being
disrespected and he kind of flipped the
ball back in the area of Big Ben and the
coach but Big Ben's turned around and it
wasn't like it was in the air it was
like flipped on the ground like I was
there any reaction at all I'm not that I
know of her done much has been made out
of I think so it sounds like too much
has been made about of that and that's
also why I think I've heard you we've
heard Big Ben say like if there was
something like that that happened at
practice I certainly wasn't aware of it
I think he's telling you the truth there
now everything I know from there all
right
I second juicy talked to five people
okay four of them told me that he missed
he left after that walked through on
Wednesday and then he missed Thursday he
missed Friday and he missed Saturday
three days three days one of them said
it was just Thursday or Friday and
Saturday okay so at four to the 500 said
it was three days and they also admin
Trident and Thursday I think the only
contact from what I've got from those
four other people was just the fact that
he let them know he was going to get his
knee looked at by another doctor which
is crazy and story did come out Thursday
that there was something out with
Antonio Browns knee right and that was
sort of what we thought was the reason
he was missing right so he did that
which like just for everybody out there
the first thing I would say is if you're
in the city of Pittsburgh the Pittsburgh
Steelers employ the best doctors okay
now there might be better doctors go
somewhere else around the country around
the world
that are more specific to what you want
to do but more times than not the top
doctors in a city and if they're not the
number one doctor then the number two
doctor okay
they work for these football teams
doctor is different than training staff
doctor is different about the training
staffs you're getting yes no this is
true like you know for a long time then
Giants head doctor was dr. Russ Warren
who were special surgery right names
Andrews exactly those type of guys right
those are the guys that are usually and
in charge of being an orthopedic surgeon
the Steelers is dr. Bradley right and I
don't know he was Bradley and he's been
the doctor there for 28 years right he's
the past president of the NFL physician
Society okay so he's pretty good is what
we're seeing there okay cuz the NFL is
not gonna make you the head of the fans
I'm just gonna say yeah I looked up best
Pittsburgh knee doctor and the first one
that popped up was dr. James Bradley you
can trust a Google search I mean when
has Google steered me wrong and it's not
even the advertiser so what but either
way so there there's just to the point
that he might not be number one but he's
up there he's in their second nugget was
that he wasn't there Friday and Saturday
and Thursday he said I'm getting
something just getting something checked
and that was it now my next big nugget
was the faculty nugget was the fact that
he responded to nobody and major people
within the organization called to try to
get in contact with a we're talking
coaches we're talking every big person I
think within the organization big front
office people maybe the owner I don't
even know I just know the major people
within the Steelers organization all
reached out and it was dark right
silence silence he didn't respond to
anybody so then they don't hear from him
on Friday they don't hear from him
Saturday okay I know this he came to the
game from what I was told to thinking he
was gonna play still like like I'm
Antonio Brown Tina what about these
people mentioned that he's done this
stuff like this wow that's where I'll
get to next okay because that's probably
where I should worth nugget well I
probably should have started there to
set that stage but I was just acting out
I like the way you did it okay good so
but then so he gets to the field and for
what I was told by these people to was
and he got to the stadium on son
a uniform was in the locker like like
what does that mean like somebody
thought he was still going to play oh so
that wasn't he would that he'll break
your old beautiful he wasn't gonna play
and he went outside in pregame warm-ups
and walked around he's seen the shots
with him in his mink coat and everything
like that and then all of these people
and I know Mike Tomlin commented on
today and said that's what he had heard
but he didn't know but all these people
told me that he left at halftime
he's known the game right so forth not a
good look for a guy who's you know what
the second highest paid on the player on
the football team in a must-win
situation we're gonna go the playoffs
just not cool I mean if the team was
upset that levian didn't show up I mean
they got to be completely furious about
Tonio Brown left them I million this
right I mean they're paying him I
haven't heard one offensive lineman come
forward yet yeah you're right so but
this is so this is the the juice I think
this might have been the juiciest nugget
fifth nugget yes is juicy nugget is a
pretty good fantasy team when I reached
out to these people okay
all but one because I told you I heard
the stories then I started to call
people that I knew would know and texted
a feel to it right sim shefter working
the phone well this is the kind of story
I didn't want to dance it on I'm a
microphone and go like I heard from one
guy and I'm gonna just go with it let's
be honest right Antonio Browns actions
have kind of annoyed you for a long time
well it didn't it's annoyed me that he
gets away with it and Odell does this
all right you know what bothers me
always in the media when one guy gets
like just absolutely same thing with
Kirk Cousins right now right and exactly
right same thing that's where I just go
crazy because I go oh wait this guy has
to abide by these standards but this guy
has a different set of standards for
some reason but back to my poignant v
nugget it's soldiers is that when I
reached out to these people four out of
the five
the first thing they responded with
right when I was just saying what did
you hear about this Antonio thing their
first text were all well listen this has
been going on with Antonio Brown for
years this kind of stuff it was all they
all started it out with that he's always
late for meetings
works his ass off but he only cares
about himself and his stats he really
could care less about anything else with
the team and that which has been
painfully clear right and then I had
somebody else text me and say like he
was like bro I mean our 8 a.m. team
meeting every every Wednesday Thursday
Friday
they were like Antonio is late for that
meeting 9 out of 10 times 9 out of 10
times
so 4 out of 5 so he's late 9 out of 10
yeah so there's you go that means like
19 out of 20 times I'm gonna give you a
9 out of 10 on your investigative
journalism there thank you
mostly the clarification of how many of
the five sources said certain things
yeah that really hit the nail on the
head that's journalism one on one story
so now I'm gonna pretend like I'm the
the host and then you're gonna be my
embedded reporter guys to be a follow-up
question I don't know if you know about
this Wow really interesting information
their reporting question is how did it
get to this point who enabled this kind
of behavior well the things I'm hearing
from my sources Adam yeah that's not the
proper way it is okay
how did it get to this point yeah
because that would be my first question
is why has this been allowed to go on
for this long well you know despite what
anybody says there's different rules
within the locker room okay there's
different even for Bill Belichick he
could say all he wants but Tom Brady
gets to do things of the other guys in
the organization don't give me one thing
whether it's mr. Wednesday practice or
take a day off for personal things
whatever it may be now he holds it very
true to the most he can possibly do okay
I so bill is still the king of keeping
everybody pretty much on an equal
playing field but yes in an NFL coaching
world you know the guy who's getting
paid the most and performing on the
field and is the guy damn near they get
away with [ __ ] there's just no other way
to say it he's the [ __ ] man nobody
was gonna pity pension Tonio brown and
be like you're 30 seconds late for our
wide receiver meeting he was gonna be
like they just it's not worth it and
they know he loves football and whatever
else so do those things dealers on the
rugs sometimes do the Steelers how did
Lawrence Taylor make it with
New York Giants but do the spoilers do
the Steelers still like Antonio Rome
from your people you talk to do you
think he's well regard in that locker
room hmm I think it's kind of like
in-between I think he's respected
because he when the lights come on he
balls and he puts in the work but I
don't think people look at him is like
the best team in the world no I don't
think that's no do you think they are
like do you think that actually like
some yeah I mean just enough I don't I
don't think they're like breaking bread
together or having Thanksgiving dinner
but they're they like each other enough
to where they can make it work on a
football field I don't have much
knowledge of that situation just as far
as that personal relationship but Ben's
handling it the proper way and saying
and doing all the right things what do
you say to people that go this is
another example of Tomlin not having
control over the lock yeah that's
ridiculous
first of all he didn't draft Antonio
Brown okay he's not the one that
resigned him and gave him all the money
either he just coaches the football team
so there's other powers to be in that
organization that have empowered Antonio
Brown you know now you know could can
Mike Tomlin have maybe handled a few
situations a little differently or maybe
even more Stern with him and at the
get-go to stop some of these things
okay maybe sure yeah I hear that but
either way it shouldn't always be about
Mike Tomlin because it's just it doesn't
always fall under his watch with every
player when he's just the coach and he's
not the GM or the guy that has final say
on the 53 I have like such a hard time
with media people saying that a head
coach is not disciplined enough it's
like I saw today people talking about
Mike Tomlin and just coming out and
attacking the culture that he's built
there and you're right like he didn't
make the decision to pay Antonio Brown
and I also say to those same media
people the same ones that celebrated
Antonio Brown twerking in the end zone
the same ones that loved him on snapchat
driving around the may back side booming
all the time right the media the fans
built Antonio Brown and they built him
because he's a wide receiver and we
loved the diva qualities yeah we loved
all the jewels and we loved all the cars
and we loved though the celebrations and
we let
get away with it in my mind because he
was not a high drafted guy he was not
out of a big school he did not get a lot
of money for the first few years and we
kind of looked at him as oh isn't this
adorable but Odell who came from the big
school and he gives you the fantasy
stats the fantasy stats but Annie played
for Pittsburgh yeah which everyone that
pays for puts Pittsburgh is blue-collar
right but I think we built this diva and
now we're sitting here going I can't
believe he's a diva look here are the
things that happened with Antonio Brown
since the end of the 2017 season this is
on the Steelers read it by a guy
aft Ryan is just the end of the 27c
season so this is know how can I show
you yeah so it's a healthy size great so
that's know Facebook live from the
locker room yet that's already happened
right all right here I mean I'm just
gonna breathe yeah
Browns get most of OTAs after he saw
Roethlisberger wasn't there
Roethlisberger later admitted he had a
pre-planned family vacation during the
optional practices Brown slammed the
media on the first day of mandatory
minicamp asking I'm playing football to
make a lot of money am i just playing
football to take care of my family
Brown showed up at a helicopter at a
training camp I don't the big idea with
that Brown disappeared for a week during
training camp Tomlin claimed that he had
been sent to Pittsburgh for medical
tests but Brown was filmed in a pool in
Miami Brown reportedly called Bichette a
racist after Bichette a reporter to be
that Brown was limping at training camp
Brown showed up more than four hours
late to an event at a Children's
Hospital offering no explanation Brown
makes a joke and a GQ article about
cheating on his girlfriend and mother of
his children saying quote it's kind of
hard to keep it in my pants
Brown threatened to assault ESPN's
undefeated reporter Jesse Washington
saying quote wait till I see you bro we
gonna see what your jaw like Brown was
spotted by CBS cameras hugging former
Browns OC Todd Haley during game against
Cleveland he was then caught bragging
about reaching 10,000 career receiving
yards to Haley on team snapchat Brown
was seen yelling an offensive
coordinator Randy Fichtner Fichtner and
my receivers coach Darryl Drake on the
sideline he didn't left his locker
before media could ask about it during
the Treece Brown tweeted trade me let's
find it I mean this is unbelievable
like all of these brown was sued for
trashing his Florida apartment claimed
he had $80,000 in cash and gun stolen
from him he was also sued for tossing
furniture from the 14th floor of an
apartment building nearly hitting and
potentially killing a 22 month old
toddler
I mean it's unreal yeah ten room and
they can't do anything because of his
salary that's the biggest thing right uh
merkon um it's 21 millions of dollars of
dead money right guess what guys what if
they trade or cut him after next season
at 17 million they they can't do
anything with a Antonio Brown for two
years yeah because they've already paid
him you told me oh yeah I didn't know
that they've already paid him loss they
don't they don't they give you signing
bonuses in Pittsburgh this is the part
of the issue would levy unbell timeout
not every team give signing bonus no
they do but they don't give you big lump
sums of guaranteed money is what I'm
saying
right so you might get something when
you sign but Antonio Browns guaranteed
money for his contract was 19 million
dollars right there was nothing we've
talked about that when Odell Beckham jr.
signed right it was nothing so the 19
million was given to him almost all
right away so then there's nothing else
on the hook so there's nothing they can
withhold from the team so there's an
issue they have with the structuring of
their contracts where they're gonna
learn now going forward to go we better
be careful about doing this in the
future because unlike a Leonard
fournette who we're seeing broke rules
and hasn't been given some of his money
or things like that the the Jaguars are
gonna go you broke some rules we're
gonna hold that we don't have to give
you some of these guarantees or we can
void guarantees or things like that
his guarantees have been given so
there's nothing to void I can't believe
the different teams structure contracts
in different way they don't believe in
guaranteed money the Pittsburgh Steelers
really it's just an organizational
philosophy it is an organizational
philosophy but yes so then they have
that but then they restructured his deal
because they've been in salary cap hell
for it seems like my whole lifetime now
yeah and they then had to move money
around give him another lump sum so
that's increased what his dead money is
so even if they cut them or like you
said trade them to another team which is
what I first thought like oh well if
they trade them to another team that was
dead money won't catch no it's gonna
count against them and they can post
June 1st
make it happen but that still would go
would have to split the 21 million what
happens whatever Brown said I'm not
coming in then he's gonna be in trouble
because then they can hold then the
whole game checks and they'll be able to
ask for parts of the signing bonus back
because the signing bonus is about the
length of the contract as well it's
Luton Pittsburgh a weird way kind of has
the pitch partner Antonio Brown pulls
Olevia or if he does yes but I mean you
know we're Pittsburgh's in a weird way
just hoping Antonio Brown maybe matures
a little bit because there that's the
best night for them yes
but yeah this is this is the issue
they're in and that's why I mean I would
be shocked if he's not back because 21
million dollars for everybody out there
is like for quality starters on your
football team I'm I want to I want to
say this at least three
I don't think Antonio Brown is a bad guy
I don't think so either I think he's in
a mixed up confused place for like the
last two years what I believe that place
is its when you make it yeah and you
think it's gonna be a certain way and
you realize that it's not yeah I think
Antonio Brown was like I want my respect
and he wanted to get the big deal and
then when he got it and he realized that
life doesn't change that much yeah it's
still the same responsibilities you have
to lead by example if there's more
eyeballs on you now and I just I don't
think he was ready for the
responsibility you know I think Antonio
Brown very much of his career was like a
number two and then he became the number
one he said you can't tell me nothing
I'm the number one yeah and I can't
imagine what it's like to be paid more
than my bosses that's right it's weird
it's gotta be weird to go in and go I
make more than you I make more than you
the entire city loves me
they don't got jerseys with your name on
the back and that's why it takes certain
guys to able to hold those positions so
then either was alright guys I was I had
nothing I was gonna keep talking for no
reason I was gonna say one of the guys
told me that that was when when they
said to redo the play he felt like
disrespected and I don't get enough love
here in Pittsburgh which I immediately
thought when I heard that did that have
something to do with juju Smith sister
getting the MVP voting for the team
right oh that was a story that came
to that juju got it right so that also
just went through my brain I don't know
anything about that by the way the other
one for thought on this stuff all the
NFL reporters that are going man maybe
juju is better than Tony yeah you heard
it here first that's fine
yeah like five weeks it's very close
exactly right right I mean it's it's
really damn close so you think maybe
there's a chance that Juju's emergence
is scaring the ego of Antonio well maybe
he just maybe feels yeah very very fair
could be certainly but I'm just I'm just
throwing out that I don't know that part
of it but I know those were some words
that were used by one of the people I
talked about and then hey I I've always
told you this and this came up again in
conversation with a few of these people
too yesterday where you know I don't
think everybody in the Pittsburgh
organization and the team thinks he's
the superstar he thinks he is you know
that's what came up with two people I
talked to yesterday right come on man he
wouldn't be I mean if he didn't have Big
Ben he wouldn't be who he is you know
that's what they're so there's that
faction there too and I'm sure he
probably hears that sometimes worse he
does so that's probably adds to the
disrespect thing too but yeah Sims one
of the best pass rushers in the NFL said
that Ben Roethlisberger's not a
hall-of-famer and Eli is there is a
perception with a B being the number one
wide receiver taken in fantasy the last
five or six years yeah that a B makes
Ben and Ben doesn't make a B because you
know what kind of a quarterback Ben is
in fantasy vendrick what round would you
take Ben Roethlisberger in fantasy 8th
12th yeah
12th he's not that great of a fantasy
quarterback because hope put up you know
282 touchdowns but guess who catches
those two touchdowns yeah right Antonio
Brown right and they go oh he made him
right yeah cam Jordan said that about
Ben good eye so I went off on it on the
NBC show this morning right I would
argue the Big Ben and let's ask big
[ __ ] Phil in a few minutes when he
comes on I would argue Big Ben is in the
conversation from one of the 10 greatest
quarterbacks of all time I would argue
he's there in that convo not saying he's
definitely there I'm just saying if
somebody came to me and was like I think
Ben's the ninth best quarterback of all
time I would go it's not crazy no I hear
what you're saying but as I'm we're
talking about this today on the NBC show
I'm literally also talking about Ben
Roethlisberger and they're showing
highlights of Antonio Brown and on every
one of them he's covered and the ball is
just dropped in his hands and I go look
I mean I know this is kind of what I'm
talking about though I mean look at
every throw we're looking at here it's
just in his hands in his hands Oh
somebody's swiping at the ball oh it's
an inch farther than the swipe in his
hands I mean it's just when I watch film
on a weekly basis
man I go wow a lot I really do
I don't know if he'll that's all guys
that oh we're doing that now it's fill
time a dude I had no idea what time we
started this pocket for ten nice seams
investigative journalism was so
impressive you lost track of time I did
oh the Steelers are you know fascinating
one of the rare teams that have the
Stars
and multiple positions and you actually
can see their egos at play yeah you know
there's and also we've been covering
these guys for so long that we know them
so well right I know there's just that
doesn't happen a lot of the other fun no
and I mean I mean he's your favorite
friends in the world really that get in
touch with me about once a month he was
all wait I forgot to tell you guys this
I forgot to tell you that was fill blood
heard about something so yesterday no no
yes it was yesterday we're on the phone
and he's like what I mean you guys
haven't called me for the podcast in a
long time he was like he was
disappointed and I was like well it's
only been like one weekend each I've
been longing that I was like you're
right it's been too and so he was these
he likes us I'd like to be normally
apologize Phil I need to tell you that
when I see you on TV and you lean in on
like James Brown and say but I mean when
you lean over and go if you come over
and watch film with me and I'm like man
I go Phil if someone ever took you up on
that offer can you offer that to
everybody
you offer that to everybody
oh I've had a few people come over
really and I'll sit there I got a I
carry my iPad with me and then I show
him something I go oh I didn't know that
of course you didn't who have you
brought over to show film to I'll tell
you off the thing I don't want to tell
you on okay very well
okay cool but you know some TV
personalities come by he's not a few
people that have come by and hung out
with dad for a day to learn school right
yeah that's what it's about so it but
you know I used to do and years ago when
I was working with Greg Gumbel when I
first got to CBS we didn't have all this
technology so I couldn't watch any film
or anything you know I would take the
game and formas on whatever but we could
only watch practice on Friday and then I
have to sit in there one of the film
rooms right and I'd watch tape that's
the only way you get that information
that's right and Greg Gumbel and ARMA
Catan was our sideline reporter and you
know they hated it they had to come in
and sit down how long we gonna watch
this
but after but after about 1 hour Greg
Gumbel would always say to me man he
goes this is so different I feel totally
different about each team and these
players after watching it this way and I
said yes
TV lies so you have to watch it
sometimes to get the real truth because
it's just that it's a whole different
dimension Adam you know it
I'm sure Christopher's got you over
showed you things and you know I didn't
know that oh I think for me the biggest
iOpener that Sims taught me was there
was a year I think about three years ago
where everybody was saying that Jason
Kelsey sucked the center for the Eagles
and SCIM and Chris angrily put on the
film and we watched like a game where
Jason Kelsey was doing everything but
what happens is what happens Phil they
let up a lot of sacks as a line and then
they've already blamed this guys they
gotta blame somebody new and then they
asked him to do something unrealistic
then that one sack gets replayed on all
the highlight shows and now he's the
reason yeah who was the quarterback
would ever give it up all these tacks no
I think it was the first parson way I
think it might have been but I'm in that
first year right yeah they were just
getting on the offensive line Elko is
always tied into the Philly you know yes
it's amazing it would never even cross
my mind to think it was Chris Chris put
on one highlight where they asked Kelsey
to to snap and then get on the outside
shoulder of Adamic and sue two gaps down
yeah and and Chris I think the strength
that Chris always has as he goes what
it's not fair for them to ask him to do
this and that's the number one thing
when I hear people say they watch film I
don't think people even understand what
football players responsibilities are on
a play and whether or not that's
feasible people blaming Anthony bar for
not covering Robert Woods what my real
story was why is he even covering Romney
well yeah I'm going first off when you
give him that responsibility you know
I'm not going to say you should be fired
but I don't know what you think yeah
you've messed up you've asked a player
to do something that he realistically
can't do I don't know what game I was
watching last week some you know I don't
know what to try to watch them all on
Sundays and revé watch them during the
week but I'm watching the game I said
wow that was a good rush my so and so he
killed a quarterback and then I go oh
well yeah and then I changed my mind
completely everybody was doing it
against a tight end right great
defensive end pass rusher being blocked
by tight end
oh yeah that's gonna work I would love
to know like some of the to reduce the
statistics and go how many of jpp sacks
were on tight ends just just to see you
know that those should be called
coaching sacks yeah yeah they're right
they should be coaching sacks it should
not be on the offensive West Coast thing
that kind of you'll never see New
England Patriots let's have the running
back blocking and we'll pull the tight
in over and we'll double-teaming right
and of course any good pass rusher just
runs right through them like they're
just swish t it looks good on a
chalkboard which I love so one thing
I've learned about the Sims family is
that a lot of traditional holidays don't
mean as much to you guys you don't
subscribe to Valentine's Day you're not
a huge fan of birthdays perfect Thank
You Phil I wasn't gonna say that but
that's great what does Phil Simms do on
New Year's what I do on New Year's Day
yesterday yeah
without New Year's Eve yeah what what
about New Year's Eve when it's like 10
they were trying to get him to go to a
little lake club in our town Christmas
Eve this is our New Year's Eve and I
know he was already throwing a fit cuz
my mom and sister told me so did he make
it there I don't know did you make it to
the Indian tribe no okay I'm gonna be
honest I'm with Phil here if I'm Phil
Simms I'm not going to the local lake
club because you know what's gonna
happen as the balls hitting zero I'm
gonna have a group of 12 men in their
50s asking me about like my tight end am
i running back from back in the day and
I'm gonna want to be in my right Phil
I'm not gonna stay up till 12 and the
week is you know as you guys know doing
all your work and Christopher you know
what I try to watch the games that I
want though the answers you guys are a
slave to film the workday if it's a
workday
okay I'm not gonna really interfere with
what I got to do cuz it once I'm behind
so it really makes me uncomfortable yeah
you stress Phil I look to be on top you
know what he likes at the end of the
week because I get my work done
Phil your son just said to me that his
one New Year's resolution would to not
allow work to be the stressor that
dominates his life and I'm realizing
this is a generational thing that you're
passing down that both of you every day
wake up and go crap I still have five
more games to watch this is insane why
do you do this I wake up and go man I
really can't go wait to go watch that
game and see what really went on I'm
watching two Cleveland Browns right now
play the Baltimore Ravens and I'm just
going Moo this is interesting or
whatever so and I couldn't wait to do it
I watched a game they played against
each other the Chargers and in the
Ravens shoot the Baltimore Ravens yeah
and I'll watch that for a second time
went man it was really a fascinating
game can't wait to talk about it so much
to talk about you never get through it
but whatever so but I I don't wake up
stressing I wake wake up looking forward
to it
what's something disrupts it and ruins
the
then I stress but Phil every day has
disruptions now when you're on chateau
de Sims and Franklin Lakes you what I
said nah well you have less distractions
because you're at Chateau de Sims and
you get to go sneak away into your
office up there yeah it's right we go
out to the other house you know I will
get into that I got there they go man
that big old office being unused as
driving me crazy Dan and like okay yeah
our psycho but Dad what the heck I was
getting ready to say but it was it was
it was but you're relieved like me that
has playoffs and you know there won't be
as much fun to watch right certain bad
teams like I even said on CBS I think
you said it Christopher I just said I
always watched Buffalo cuz Josh Allen
man it was just right all right so let
me ask you Phil of the four games what
is something that you've learned from
your film about one of the four games
that you think no one's talking about
right now that could be a really good
juicy I'm not even near that point yet
to say that because I'm really just well
I would say I've only really
accomplished the Chargers and the Ravens
alright let's talk about that KCBS I'm
spending extra time on it and you know
by the time we get on the air two of
those games are going to be over so I'm
gonna watch them superficially myself
and then of course I'll watch them and
I'll have a have you know if we'd sure
we'll talk about it on Sunday a little
light we'll get a little comment a bit
on it but it won't be anything in depth
so I'm not going to crush myself on
cowboy film which I kind of know anyway
and right now if you film or any of
those some of those teams because I
already know them I don't well where do
where do you alright so since you're
gonna be on Sunday at 1:00 for maybe the
game of the weekend with Chargers Ravens
it's honestly me and Chris we're talking
about earlier kampf using game yeah I
don't know which way to go in that one
but what are you saying I'm just gonna
say the Saturday games like I'm not
saying you got to pick them right now I
didn't even see Showtime you're inside
the NFL show yet
it was a train wreck so that you didn't
miss anything so so but what so where
you leaning just give me a clue here
where you leaning in with Colts Texans
I'm leaning Colts right now just so you
know I'm leaning Colts they got the
offensive line we know about all that
I like your defense the one thing that
worries me their defense has a lot of
young guys and you know I call them car
chasers yes right yeah no I gotta go get
it right that's see that's kind of a big
issue and I'm gonna watch the Titans
game of the Colts just to see well gosh
the Titans offense what am I going to
learn watching it yeah it's hard yeah I
mean it there was not any of these
things that would confuse the defense so
I've made it easy on them you're right
so yeah I'm leaning to the Colts just
because of their offensive line you can
throw it down the field on the Texans
everybody's doing it you know and then I
just say it this way and I think I said
it on air last week I'm not sure the the
Houston Texans they have stars and they
do they got stars yes the problem is
they don't have enough supporting actors
and and that's kind of how I look at
them this parade pass rush got these
guys well what if they don't get there
then we get shredded you know right you
know what my thing is to attend people
miss and make the throw
yeah and there's nothing there right I
would also say this let's just break it
down better offensive line Colts better
quarterback right now I would pick
Andrew Luck better head coach I would go
reich better defensive coordinator I
would go Eber flus better wide receiving
corps I would go Houston I think I don't
know I don't know biggest receiving
corps I think if you're including tight
ends and repass catching running backs
defensive line defensive line Texans
linebackers you can make an argument for
the Colts different styles secondary I
would say probably the Texans Texans
have more talent their scheme is maybe
not as Chris always says the big
strength of the Texans is dominating you
at their front
or and as we've seen from the cults
twice against the Texans and against
every team in the NFL
you're not going to dominate them that's
right you know the other thing is to JJ
Watt is a great pass rusher and
sometimes to me like Aubrey pass rushers
I he when he plays outside
there's too many plays that get made
inside yeah yeah but he plays inside I
love him money lies up inside to rush
the passer because now he's not going to
create a draw a lane that you can run
draws in that you can run in or you can
throw screens behind him you know you're
going while you see screens going behind
the outside pass rusher but you know
they if they don't get there then they
just I've watched too much of the tape
the success rate is extremely high
against that defense and you've said it
there pass protections awesome
yeah and it's it's it's one of those
games
Houston session is it extreme big-time
wild card yes right you know you can
take over here get sacked 6-times or he
might throw four touchdowns and throw
for 400 yards who knows yeah all right I
want to ask you I know you went to the
Saturday night game I really want to
know Phil what's your feeling then about
Ravens Chargers like what's your gut
telling you having watched a bunch of
film already well it kind of goes both
ways that the Ravens defense is
borderline spectacular really I can't
really say anything bad about it
I used to say if they just had one speed
as rusher that's kind of changed a
Darius Smith number 90s kind of turned
into a God that can make moves shoot
even their big guys inside but their
scheme is tremendous and of course they
I think them the Ravens and the Patriots
have the two best secondaries in
football let's say the charge is got a
really good secondary to yes I mean it's
it's right up there and the Chargers
Brandon me bein that would be the thing
that I look at Brandon me bein you look
at that game they played out there
whatever what was your what's your first
thought about when when they played out
there and I'm telling me what you think
I think you think
the game with the charges of Ravens play
what do you think that the Doremus just
dominate the whole game no I think when
I really look back at it they didn't
dominate as much as I thought they would
just physically pushing them away right
when you watch it you just go no no if
you really think about it I mean like
hun just bring it down to this yeah that
fumble recovered for a touchdown
yeah the Chargers were driving down to
possibly take the lead right that was
happening right that's where it was my
gosh should have took the safety and
they should have punted it away remember
that and but you're right I don't think
they would have scored going down okay
guys I just don't
I did but I also I said this to Chris
earlier there was Keenan Allen got hurt
early in that game and there was no
Melvin Gordon and Austin heckler missed
the game too yeah here's the other thing
too that really caught me by surprise
you take away like any game but it
really stood out there's like only four
plays that really stand out from the
Ravens offense and that game mm right
and you touched down to the tight end in
the beginning a game they get a couple
big runs yeah the big throw to who was
at Andrews on my mark yeah you take that
out and I mean there's a lot of a lot of
couple yards this that Lamar I would the
eyes were covered it's it's that part is
going to be really interesting to me
the Chargers defense how the what they
learn not didn't learn they played
really well against the Ravens the first
time I think they probably go think they
can even do better soon I would make
which they did make Lamar Jackson throw
the football keep him in the pocket but
make him throw against man-to-man
coverage that's it making make tight
throws that's that's kind of what the
Patriots have always done against
certain quarterbacks can you complete
the pass against man-to-man coverage and
their defensive backs are good enough to
stand the receivers that's for sure yeah
our our my Philadelphia Eagles poised
for another magical run it's not going
to be on the film Phil there's nothing
for you to see there's no statistics for
you to look up there's no film to
dumb numbers it's Maddie yeah third down
there you completely I love that I'm one
of my failing situational I gotta be
good at situational football we're
talking with spirit I don't know what
that mean we're talking the spirit of
magic the spirit ng qu well you know
what's the old thing emotions great T
gets smacked in the face then you gotta
play I don't know so they're gonna be
interesting both of you are in the
Chicago offense is dynamic enough to
really pull away right Eagles yeah I
don't and I think the Eagles or what's
the word for it cute enough on offense
to get rid of the football which they do
very quickly and they are very happy to
throw for four yard games the whole game
is they have you know what I thought
about you dad when I watched that film
yeah Philadelphia no offense I watched
yet I can't wait because I know what
it's gonna be even though I didn't even
watch it on Sunday yeah it's not pretty
but I'll say this
it's something I'm gonna give you credit
for that we've talked about a little bit
over the last few weeks the one thing
that I think about the Philadelphia
Eagles that I do like they change this
since Carson Wentz which is it still
pisses me off I'm rooting against you
guys because [ __ ] you guys changed your
game plan once the better quarterback
got hurt is they have become like you
said not afraid of third and two yep and
that is there's only a few teams in
football that are not afraid of that
they're not afraid to be in the
situation of third and two and what
dad's point is when we had this
conversation a few weeks ago any spot on
because this is New England and it's the
New Orleans Saints they don't panic when
it's second and nine and go we gotta
throw an 11 yard completion and get the
first down they go let's run it up the
middle again and get four yards and
maybe we'll get into third and five or
third fourth or let's throw a wide
receiver screen and get us a third and
second and then you stirred into and we
go we watch Brady we go they're never
gonna stop New England on third and two
I mean they can do whatever they want
right how many times have we sat
together and watch the game and said
that that's the one thing I like about
your Eagle team they've been doing ways
it's for teams like Philadelphia
New England all that they have so many
ways to because they're for a half the
beat and there they go with the four
yard or six yard gain or whatever no
situations right that's it so yeah
you're you're so right they're not
afraid of all those situations and also
I gotta give him you know yeah Peterson
I've never seen just sits over there
it's four to one on your own forty year
we're going for here let me get a play I
mean just look at that she doesn't even
like I think doesn't likes to go for it
always on fourth down I know they don't
but I've never seen I don't think I've
seen a coach be so blatantly unafraid of
the consequences as I have Doug Peterson
it's because they've already died it's
the second year in a row the season
hopes died and they go we're playing
with house money what who cares if we
don't get it well you know to it's
easier now to call all these plays on
point
with that Super Bowl trophy in his back
all right
Chris is Chris is yelling at us he has
one more because man we're getting a lot
of fill this week and I love that we
were talking about all right just tell
ya first of all who you lean in Seattle
Dallas cuz the fans are gonna go away he
talked about three games
I think the Dallas Cowboys are one of
those teams just like we saw against the
Saints they can be so high and so
emotional at home yeah and you know
they're crowd I give them credit man
they're their crowd can get into it and
that definitely will be a factor and
we're talking about you know when you
look at the Seattle Seahawks there's a
lot to like and it's it's an
unbelievable job by Pete Carroll I
thought they'd win four or five games
and here they are into playoffs right
and the way they've done it but hey
their offensive line is still what it is
and they don't stop to run great I just
think there's there's too many not good
on the road that we're yet there works
form at home they're not gonna work when
they go away from so I think the Cowboys
a win I thought it was awesome I saw you
this morning Christopher showing dak
Prescott touchdown throw right I meant
it the more I just said wow there's
really great I don't want and but they
don't give him enough chances to be that
guy either right he's a young
quarterback plane you know run run it's
third and six now make the throw yeah
he's playing 1989 giant snowball you
know 1990 1990 1990 but yeah but look I
was older I mean okay third and five
here we are again you know it was a
different world don't worry we picked up
third downs at an unbelievable rate that
year because we were definitely not
afraid of going run run pass you do that
to a young quarterback that is truly
unfair you got to keep him in the game
at all times
give him easy completions move him
around all that stuff and you know I
really believe the Cowboys will of
course they're gonna run it hard but I
think they're slowly evolving realizing
hey men we just can't win this way we
got to have a little get here and give
our margin of error we got to make it
bigger Yeah right done that it was
really fun to see dak Prescott get to
throw the football 40 times well Chris
has an all-time quarterback question for
you yeah it's my last last thing well I
you know we were talking about Antonio
Brown on the Big Bend situation right
right and then you know of course
Antonio Browns awesome I'm not trying to
take away from that but I also you know
I do try to explain to the listeners how
awesome Big Ben is and maybe I'm wrong
here with your I don't even know what
you're gonna say here but I do believe
Big Ben is awesome I think because he's
you know had some bad moments of looking
like a jerk off the field that people
don't really evaluate what he does on
the field and I said the left go that I
would argue that Big Ben is in the
conversation for one of the 10 greatest
quarterbacks of all time I'm saying he
might not be number you know but if
somebody came to me and said hey I think
Big Ben's the ninth best quarterback of
all time I'd go out that's not crazy I
could live with that and I just wanted
to hear what you thought about Big Ben
just career wise and kind of where he
stacks up well I don't know if I put him
in the top 10 because I had to think
about that but it would be in the top 15
for sure yeah I think that people don't
yes people don't give him the credit he
deserves he's like I've always said he
is a passer
thrower he is unbelievable touch he is
graceful for a big old guide is a big
dude
but he's a beautiful graceful thrower
the football he throws the football to
Antonio Brown all the time you know what
I know it into double coverage but he
makes the perfect roll they completed
you and I just said there go why would
he even look at him when he knew he was
double team because he knew there was
gonna be a little window there and he
could drop it in there and so that but
what he needs to he can turn on the
power and he's an older quarterback yes
he's not mobile but the difference is he
can stand there and you know I heard it
too many times doing games defensive
lineman telling me hey man when you hit
brothers burger now it's different
really is it really good oh man it's
like you know you running do you think
you're running into another D lineman
not get out there and he can stand in
the pocket and literally take his left
hand and kind of hold somebody off as
he's rocking his right arm back to throw
it I mean I've never seen anything like
it and his he's pinpoint accurate almost
always and that throwing arm of his is
gonna outlast everything else on that
body yeah and so you know he's one guy
that you know when you look at all the
quarterbacks I saw it happened to Kirk
Cousins this year he got hit too much
and there comes a point when you can
only take getting hit so you get tired
of it where's your body down and I
thought I saw that in Kirk Cousins right
but Ben Roethlisberger shows no signs of
what we call what do we call Christopher
cabin fever yeah right never he can be
surrounded and can't move and he's like
how somebody's gonna be open I'll wait
right and he makes the throws so I've
always been a big fan I did so many
other games watching him practice
watched him warm up watching the outcome
seeing it they never gets mentioned is
one of the better quarterbacks the NFL
and well there's no doubt I can argue
that all day that he is yeah all right
man you the man thanks for coming on
hey you don't great you know I'll talk
to you guys I guess in February okay
well no Phil I'm hoping maybe
championship well it still gonna have to
work to him in ship weekend yeah mi of
course of course the CBI
well Phil maybe I'll just come up and
watch a game at your house cuz your
son's working too much to watch with me
and Josh if it's just you and me yeah
well he's gonna work now yeah well you
know a listen Adam when you find that
job where I not to do anything they pay
me man I'm all-in
yes you go find it for me I got a place
there all week yeah
in fact we're trying to get you e yeah
what are you doing yeah maybe we'll do
something Friday night Phil um I think I
got to work like a really long day on
Saturday from what I understand about
you know the rehearsal of a 14-hour
pregame show well we're gonna play ping
pong live in front of a studio audience
at the Super Bowl what do you think I
think when I see you I'm gonna punch you
in the face perfect I'll still be your
ass in ping-pong even if I have a broken
jaw second caught me off guard
just remember yeah there are a lot of
damn sims's down in Kentucky so be
careful yeah Super Bowl is in Kentucky
watch out I went to my buy my
grandmother's funeral right down in
Springfield Kentucky
when was this it was like three four
years ago yeah where my kids got to see
their first dead person you know in a
casket right and I mean they ran in like
it was a new toy I think you said
there's a Popeye's I'm pretty sure I did
but we went down to Springfield where my
dad was born and raised and yeah we
wanted to do the cemetery and I swear
like half the cemetery said Sims on the
gravestones I was like damn I am from
Kentucky aren't I
speaking of dying the booger mobile
looks to be dead dead he's gonna be in
the booth Oh playoff game Wow bigger boo
boo oh wow which i think was probably a
smart idea yeah he was in the booth last
game yes you yeah so that's good good
for them uh before I do some of your
film notebook I want to just mention
names that are being mentioned for
possible coaching jobs and I just want
your honest take and if your
anything I kind of want to move quickly
so it's not there is one name though
that you're hearing that I'm not hearing
a lot right Munchak Mike Munchak yes
this is a Sims exclusive it's a Sims
exclusive I do know Mike Munchak is very
high on three or four teams out of the
eight openings where he's looked at as a
lead candidate or if not the lead
you know the second guy but at the top
of the list currently the Steelers
office Steelers officer line coach was
the head coach of the Tennessee Titans
was the old line coach when I was there
in Tennessee
he's though he was the head coach when
they drafted Jake Locker okay he was the
fall guy well he was he was the fall guy
and he really wasn't the fall guy the
story I've always known there is that he
was they were gonna try to force him to
fire people along the staff and he said
no you can just fire me I'll fire the
people I think need to be fired and
that's what happened so it wasn't even
because of that okay but he is without
question just so you know without a
doubt one of the best coaches I've ever
been with at any position and offensive
line coach ooh I mean it's a tough one
between him or score Nekia but those are
the two of the best I've ever been
around
yes high praise Marvin Lewis says Hugh
Jackson should get the Bengals job
that's crazy that's called when keeping
it real goes wrong or you're too close
to your friend and you have bias he's
getting an interview
I mean that's fine that's good for an
interview but I just I don't know
amazing say yes I mean the people of
Cincinnati said pillage the streets with
pitchforks and flames if he becomes the
head coach of the Bengals all right I'm
gonna start just listing off names and
you tell me what about any of the
coaches that recently got fired bowls
gays Joseph cutter Marvin Lewis McCarthy
Wilkes Jackson any of those guys deserve
an immediate another chance well I mean
I think I look at gays and go okay that
was I think maybe a year too early for
me and my leggings and I think there's
some spots out there I wouldn't be
shocked if like a team like the Arizona
Cardinals went gay right something like
that
he's supposedly a guy that works well
with exactly right exactly right so I
look at gays and then hey Mike McCarthy
as well if I was Mike McCarthy I'd
probably sit out of here
I would I probably would just repair my
but what are there any of these jobs
though like Browns are worth coming out
right now
Browns are maybe the Jets are too I mean
the Jets I mean there seems to be some
wanting here in the New York area I
don't have any inside info over how the
Jets feel about Mike McCarthy well if
you want to know how the error would go
in the Jets that's how it always goes
yeah they get a new coach it's the same
year they have a lot of salary cap they
spend all of it on big-name free agents
they over perform by like two games and
go eight and eight and then because they
spent all their money in the first year
they give them nothing and they lose
free agents for the next two or three
and then you get fired yeah that's what
happened to Rex it's what happened to
Boles they just keep doing the same
thing over and over you're I can't
really argue with that so so Jase and
McCarthy but you would advise McCarthy
to sit out a year I would I I think I
would yes and you know of course the
people that are gonna throw a curve ball
in this whole conversation there's two
names I mean dual John Harbaugh I mean
because we don't know what's gonna
happen there and there's still a lot of
things the seams like that need to be
done and said they're in Baltimore and
then of course Bruce Arians who's you
know been out a year who's another guy
that I look at and go yeah he could
throw a wrench into this whole situation
is I thought he was only interested in
Cleveland he's interested in Tampa Bay
he came out and said it and I said well
okay I believe when I first heard it too
I thought the same thing I was like I
don't know about that but then I also
thought wait Bruce Arians might be the
kind of guy that could get like well I
thought okay he it's like a buddy cop
yeah well I would also get scared there
would be like two buddy and also it
could be like gameis thinks he's the man
and then he just loose and does whatever
I just know Bruce Arians offense with
those weapons holy crap Tampa I think is
a really sneaky good job I really do it
all comes down to whether or not what
you get out of James Jameis is of course
the huge elephant in the room yes but
you know you look at the rest of it
first of all I look at Tampa and go
Bruce Arians would be great for Tampa he
will sell tickets because people are
gonna make who is this crazy guy with a
Kangol hat saying all these funny things
to the press conference
he's gonna get people to go to the game
to get interest in the team just by his
personality he is a quarterback
offensive genius
we know that and we've talked about it a
lot this year I mean it's Mike Evans
okay it's OJ Howard it's you know white
boys supreme Humphries in the slot
doesn't sound like DeSean Jackson's
gonna be there but that the other kid
from Penn State I'm blanking on his name
right now the offensive line Godwin
right the offensive line we talked about
it has a pretty good size they got the
defensive line already too so you have
pieces there and so I don't think it's
the worst spot is what I was right I'm
gonna aim too long you did I'm gonna
name other names you tell me in your
mind if you believe they're ready to be
a head coach and if any of these spots
are attractive to ya
Eric be enemy I do I do I do I think
he's ready to be a head coach if Matt
Negi is so is he it's the same type of
path I believe he could do that he's
been at least an offensive play caller
for a very good offense as we know and
to be the offensive play caller under
Andy Reid you have to be respected and
trusted by Andy and I think that shows
me enough that he deserves to be a head
coach Dan Campbell without a doubt Dan
Campbell is Mike Vrabel except he's the
offensive version right he's gonna bring
attitude and toughness and detail to
your football team he'd probably be just
like Vrabel the only head coach to be
out there blocking with the tight ends
before the game doing those kind of
things yes Matt Campbell coach of Iowa
State yeah I don't know enough about him
I do I am I respect him though and how
they play Iowa State has made a name for
themselves in the big 12 playing not big
12 football by basically blowing no
we're gonna play good sound defense and
we're gonna get any eye formation and
run and they do different things they've
had a number of eyes always extremely
well respected I just don't know enough
about him personally
Eber fluffs well I I think so yes Eber
flow this is my view man one caveat
though with guys like this and the day
of the quarterback whisperer and the
owners the only thing they know our
quarterbacks and an offensive numbers is
the defensive coach still a thing
is he a thing and if he is a thing that
Evo flus better have an offensive
coordinator he's attached with to get
the job a la a damn Quinn with Kyle
Shanahan and the Atlanta Falcons they
better have a guy to go I'm bringing him
with me as my OC it's the first year
I've heard a lot of people
Vic Fangio ya and meaning it yes I I
mean I of course we get it it does sound
like it's a little more real coach
though yes okay yeah with an offensive
mom I'm Brian Flores you've always
already talked about yeah um Kliff
Kingsbury negative and I got respect for
cliff so I want to preface it with this
first I do think he could be a head
coach in the NFL one day I really do but
I don't think people who have spent
their life in college football know what
they're getting into
when it becomes the NFL it's one thing
to game plan against Oklahoma State who
runs the same two defenses all game long
and then you only have 20 hours a week
to prepare your football team so
therefore you only have about 15 or 20
plays to and then you have to play the
Baltimore Ravens do you think you're
gonna go into that with that attack my
big thing is offensive young geniuses in
the NFL everyone's trying to find
McVeigh and Shanahan right has
everybody's trying to find they their
life was in the NFL McVeigh was coaching
a top-tier offense and the officer
coordinator for the Washington Redskins
Kyle Shanahan led Matt Ryan to an MVP
and was a top-five offense with the
Houston Texans and sha'ban Andre Johnson
and invented the rg3 offense but they
came up through NFL DNA coaches who
don't come up through NFL DNA Steve
Spurrier Chip Kelly it doesn't work out
good so that's what I would say about
those type of guys Zach Taylor
quarterback coach of the Rams a lot like
cliff he's going to be a head coach one
day I know Zach I was with him in Tampa
before he has head coach materials and
it Factor gotta be an offensive
coordinator first that's [ __ ] insane
for somebody to think oh the guy who's
doing the quarterback room is now gonna
come unto our team and be the offensive
coordinator and coach the whole team if
anybody goes along that line that is
insane and one day he will be but let's
let him be a play caller first before we
make him in charge of a billion-dollar
organization Freddie kitchens I think he
needs another gear Oh being a top-notch
OC I can't believe Matt Lafleur still
being mentioned by people that simply
say lasers being ridiculous Matloff or
it I do think maybe in his DNA but
anybody that's got just watch Tennessee
Titans offense this year you can't say
Matt Lafleur what and then do you think
Chuck Pagano can come
you mentioned that before I respect
Chuck a lot and I think he's a lot
better coach than people have given him
credit for I would probably say that
yeah and I kind of drug I would not be
mad if he became a head coach at all
it's a fascinating year and then my
other name would be like Zack Taylor
should be a guy one of those defensive
coaches should bring along to become the
OC Vic Fangio I got a job call Zach
Taylor and bring him as your OC let him
be the OC two years and then he can go
move on and be a head coach do you think
anyone has the confidence to pull the
trigger on Josh McDaniels after what
happened I think most teams are gonna be
extremely turned off about it I don't
really have any inside info people were
turned off by New England coaches and
Josh McDaniels as is you know just so
funny it is funny right but it's just
kind of you're going to say they're
elitist when really they are the elitist
they're elite they're the elitist of the
elite or the elitist and then they come
off as more elitist because before games
and things like that they don't talk to
the other coaches because it's all
business it's just funny to me like I
think about everyone they're working
environments and like people come in and
they're like this isn't the way that it
happened in New England like listen it's
not New England it's like yeah but you
hired me to make it more like New
England and I'm telling you your
organization is run like [ __ ]
right I know I know that's exactly it
yeah you know it's you've always said
man not every team's trying to win the
Super Bowl
then don't hire a coach that only knows
how to try in Super Bowls right he's
gonna make my uncomfortable something
with the Bengals I'm so excited to see
who the Bengals hire because for 18
years or however long it's been with
Marvin Lewis 16 18 years we've never had
to see the kind of guy they'd go out and
get and what direction they're trying to
go into it's always been status quo
maybe we'll flip the coin and happen to
win it this year yeah but now we get to
really see how expensive how much money
will they spend on a coach what kind of
a coach will they go for it right
because in my mind Cincinnati has never
been a team trying to win the Super Bowl
ever Cleveland hasn't been a team trying
to win the Super Bowl either they've
been trying to win the AFC North right
yeah that's right yeah the Jets have
never been trying to win the Super Bowl
in my mind
never know even when they were really
good with Rex he was just going let me
just try to beat New England the AFC's
that's all he was already Denver has yes
and that's why Ravens do the Steelers do
you know the Saints do they're going for
Super Bowls Eagles do they do exactly
right uh you wouldn't watch some film
yeah what did you see from watching Nick
Foles um I think the biggest thing once
again with Nick Foles if we just had to
talk specifically about him I am amazed
with him right again I will say that
he's not as talented as Carson Wentz but
I'm going to say the thing that I do
love about his game he's great with
people around him loud like mom and dad
was talking about Big Ben Roethlisberger
I'm not saying he's Big Ben but he is
unfazed by people around him and the
Potters were talking about this
Negi was saying you watch them on film
you realize how big he is yeah he's a
big member he never gets distracted by
the run no he just never never flinches
there's never of anything like that and
the other thing that always jumps out to
me is just how good of a covered thrower
he is it's the number one attribute that
he has over Carson Wentz yes it's the
reason why Al Shean explodes with him on
the field I think there's some truth to
that certainly his ability to go oh I'm
under pressure Oh al Sean or whoever is
covered but I think I can put it in this
spot and they can still get it he is got
a knack for that and he's very natural
at that so I always give him credit for
that you know the other thing I would
just go with your team to again I'm
angry at them a little bit is because I
mean it's just downhill run every play
now I love it I mean that's right I mean
and your offensive line is healthy they
look healthy they're playing healthy yes
so that beginning where Peters was out
every other game right they were they
were messing with Wisniewski or even
yeah and then he got hurt a little too
Wisniewski right
our right your right tackle yeah yeah
the high ankles that's a tough injury so
my bold prediction for Sunday yeah
you're gonna see Leonard Floyd on his
ass more than he's ever been all year
that skinny [ __ ] going down I'm
getting angry yeah sounds like yeah [ __ ]
you but I'm getting uh but it was good
to watch you they they played the whole
game with a scheme they played one of
their best games as far as just
offensive line is concerned against the
Redskins
you're telling me one of the scariest
teams in the playoffs
is also clicking kind of I'm not gonna
sit here and go oh my gosh they scored
24 against the Redskins and their inept
II might now this is the frickin Bears
and they're a little different animal
this week but it's encouraging
nonetheless one other thing I'll say
about your football team just so we go
and we're gonna watch out for that yes I
know it's yours is I would be a little
worried about them I don't want to say
repeating concepts but I feel like I
have a very good feel and formations
where the wrong to go right well luckily
the Bears don't have a great DC that was
what worries mine that's what worries me
a little bit is that that kind of stuff
right what did you see on film from the
Bears defense the Bears defense you know
I think the interesting thing was
against the Vikings yes the Bears
defense you know I don't even know what
was the firt I mean first off I watched
the Redskins defense and then went into
the Bears defense right so that's that
I went back-to-back and then one thing I
mean eternal a Bears film and I don't
know another level you do as soon as you
turn it on you just go damn it just
seems like they're moving faster
everywhere and they seem like they're
bigger on the screen and all those
things so that's the first thing you
noticed you just goes seems like the
massive blue and white is moving faster
to the ball than the other teams I just
watched on film the only thing that I
like for the Eagles is they did just
play Jadeveon Clowney and and sure JJ
Watt you're not going to play Aaron
Donald and Reich ensue right but the
problem with all the teams the Eagles
face the last three weeks the Bears have
a better offensive line than all of them
they do their better offensive line and
this is still the best d line and the
best front 7 is awesome as JJ and clowny
are this is they're not the Bears so
what else do you see on the deef you
know so that's and you know they are
when I talk about being able to predict
where you guys are throwing the ball at
times you okay yeah I was gonna need a
bathroom break no it's good but when we
talk about like how I worry about your
offense and I can see where the ball
goes
you know the one thing I look about your
offense or certain formations where I
know what kind of play is coming and you
guys do like to run these certain
crossers or earths about ten yards right
over the middle set you ain't gonna get
that [ __ ] against Chicago there's nobody
better in football and stop and crossers
and that kind of crap because of that
let us summon linebacker and
also what's funny about who they played
last week the Vikings of course cuz addy
Filippo have some of those carryover
plays that you guys run and the Bears
are all over the fourth and two at the
end of the game where Diggs caught it
yes and got hit as he caught it that was
kind of an Eagles play but they were
like you're not gonna throw that crap on
us we have a feeling you're gonna go to
this and they blew him up so that's a
Bears advance that's a Bears advantage
there certainly I mean the Bears D when
I really look at it I do one of the
things I wrote is big thing is the Bears
D has no weakness schematically I was
gonna fire wise for you there's really
no weakness other than Batman
McManus maybe 27 because they lost Bryce
Callahan it was a really good nickel
corner for them
so maybe that so Nelson Aguilar has to
explode in the slot yeah yeah they're
gonna have to that's maybe the guy if
they do get man-to-man or get in those
situations good for Darren Sproles the
face are bad pretty bad because there's
so much fakes faster than all right
they're just fast they play good zone
coverages when they try to do those
little wheel routes out of the backfield
they're gonna be sitting there waiting
gonna do against this team yeah and that
would be the big thing and I would think
that would be tough sledding because
those two in the middle down to Al Shean
own lobby it's certain your run game I
mean I you know I'm not gonna say I'm
gonna count your run game even though
there are awesome unrung defense I mean
if you can just keep them honest it can
be a different football game now the
other thing too with the Bears old-line
because I watch the last side code
eparchy the former Eagle to miss three
field goals the bear which would be
great
bears old lines healthy like you guys
are you know Kyle Long's back now they
got everybody in the right spot and
that's why they ran for 170 yards
against the Vikings last week you know
so that'll be interesting to you have to
deal with that and what I would say to
and I'm guess I'm gonna say and now even
though I should save it oh don't say it
don't say it fine cuz it's gonna impact
my better go write it down so you don't
forget okay mark attack like normally I
would just take that than completely use
it I could just it's just a
schematically it out you want me to I
don't care yeah now my big thing would
be any time you're playing this kind of
team Matt Nagy Kansas City Chiefs one
thing I've always noticed when they were
with the Kansas City Chiefs when it
became big must-win games or playoff
game tight no Alex Smith runs they have
design runs for him like and if you go
back
Colts game but they burgle weed or
Pittsburgh or any other games throughout
the last few years they will run Alex
Smith in these games and I would say
watch out for Mitch to do risky you know
runs if I was a Bears fan the number one
thing I want is run Mitchell early get
him comfortable have the crowd going
nuts for him you know do a nice little
bootleg where he comes out the back and
picks up 40 yards and drops the ball and
says first down yeah let shock aah go
love him because if I'm a Bears fan yeah
that's my fear yeah is that mitch is
gonna lose this game for me trust me
it's so I want screen if I'm a Bears fan
which I'm not yeah I'm rooting against
this I want screens to Tariq early I
want bootlegs where he's running and I'm
letting him take a shot to Benjamin yeah
I get that that's what they should do
that that's how I'm starting the game if
I'm the Bears fan the one thing I've
also noticed with them on offense it
does they put you in a bind when you
want to play man-to-man and it's really
mid Negi has the plays of course to
stress you in your man-to-man he's got
all the essentials you need to pick or
Bunch or whatever switches whatever all
it is but the other issue that you
people sleep on when you play man
against against the Bears
it's too risky running again yeah
because now you only got one guy for him
or if that middle linebacker who's kind
of just playing it's like free and he's
trying to keep his eye on the
quarterback but crossers he takes one
wrong step and all sudden true risky
steps up 40 or see it exactly right so
you have to be careful about when you
pick the play man or two man against
true risky because his legs become the
sixth receiver as we would say in the
NFL are at the quarterback for Fletcher
lining up well it would be Kyle long and
you know the kid Daniels the second
round from Iowa right last thing you
looked up some stuff on the Colts
offense yeah I mean the Colts are just I
always like to watch and what they do I
only watch their own lot or offices
against the Titans against the Titans
you know they're just such a force I
don't know what else to say you know the
game planning by Frank Reich of courses
is very impressive on a weekly basis
we're not exaggerating quit Nelson's
impact no definitely not Quintin
Nelson's two all-pro guard him and Zack
Martin to the two best guards
they're the two best cards in football
and called Nelson I would say this year
has been the best card in football and
you know I like Zack Martin and some
other guys and I am willing to say that
Quentin Nelson is the best guard in
football but this is where they put you
in a bind not only are they hulking and
they can just run and and collapse the
side of the line to run the football you
know their pass protection is what they
really screw you at left Co and you know
this I know I'm not preaching to the
choir here but where they put you in a
bind on the defensive side of the ball
as you go you know oh gosh you watch
film and you go oh man we got to worry
about T why hild and the Chester Rogers
Annie Braun downfield we got to keep
seven deep you know just to try to stop
these passes but then when you do that
you only rush four and he's got all day
and then eventually he picks you apart
doing that yeah so then you go into the
binding go luck we'll go through all
five people go out he'll we'll be as
patient as possible and he's not afraid
to sit there and take the shot to wait
for the 30 yard completion come open so
he does that so so then the defensive
coordinators go well to him he's got all
day and he's picking us apart so let's
rush fiver let's rush Hicks and you know
what happens when teams rush five and
rush six six
he's got all day again yeah and it
doesn't matter it and more times or not
they stone those type of blitzes to
where now you go well we were trying to
get pressure on him but we really didn't
get much pressure and T why he'll and
then some of these receivers are wide
open down the field again or they're in
a matchup that you like and he's a great
down the field thrower so that's where
they really stress you they should have
won that game and put that game away so
much quicker than they did the other
night I mean come on of course a pick
six you know they're in field goal
position and Marlin mcfumbles I mean
that game was about to get out of hand
and they they kept a minute but they're
just dangerous they are dangerous way of
use what you said earlier today yeah if
the Colts beat the Texans yeah it is
very possible right they're
automatically playing them right and if
there's a team that Kansas City doesn't
want to face right it might be the Colts
because
Houston and Chris Jones and D Ford
probably are not gonna get to Andrew I'm
not gonna ruin the game Andrew Luck
might put up 55 on the Colts I mean
their Chiefs yes that's what I mean yes
no I would that's what scare me which
makes me as a gambler
there are some interesting like matchup
bets where you like if I could already
predict the Colts in the AFC
Championship game right which is the
reason I'm sending the Patriots to the
Super Bowl
yeah I hear you know I hear because
Andrew well Andrew Luck in New England
what if the Super Bowl bro I know I
don't think it's crazy it's not not in
the AFC not this year again I can't
stress to anybody enough I have no
vested horse than this and that is
telling you as a fan no vested [ __ ] no
vested horse in this took that in
addiction no horse in this race I have
no vested interest combined or a vested
horse best reading between the tea
leaves well reading between the tea
leaves I said I'm registered G leaves
but I'm also reading between the lecture
deep that's extra deep I'm just
imagining like a forest of what are
these things
tea leaves my only thing that I'm
thinking that I love about it yes if the
Colts get to the Super Bowl yeah and the
Saints make it right and get a rematch
of Saints Colts but it also makes me it
also makes me think I could totally say
that the Super Bowl doesn't count that
much for the scenes because they played
a succeed Saint hater it's hilarious I
was wondering where you're going all
right did you watch any other film or
that was it no that was that I've been
skipping around that was all I wrote
down the doc I don't know if you watch
it yes no all right so what brings a
weird week with New Year's so we're
gonna bring in and recast is Nick gonna
call it's gonna call him Enrique Enrique
just for your knowledge as a lifelong
Raiders fan okay been listening to the
pod since 2014 discovered Sims and Lefko
in the BR app and the name of his team
was the big [ __ ] from The Sims
metrical conference and I think he
posted on Instagram after he won the
Grand Championship and he said my team
name is big [ __ ]
and then he clarified that that was your
dad's nickname and that he didn't just
pick a random two words to name it we
knew that yes and I think like first of
all that's a great name to win in the
first SNL League we should probably get
him a big [ __ ] autograph or something
I'll do that for
look at that Enrique hey what's up guys
what's up man how you doing
congratulations man we're proud of you
thanks man it feels good so good to be
the Grand Champion
Oh s LFL inaugural inaugural Grand
Champion I'm looking at your team it was
say Kwan the horse that carried you the
whole time
yeah it would say Kwan you know and
earth o the Earth's inator yeah that's a
pretty good squad you had together I
mean for a fantasy football I mean you
got some unbelievable of a production Oh
tell me the rest of the team let me hear
the rest of it okay so you know I picked
up Robert Woods and you know what this
is funny but this is my first time I did
PPR oh yeah I'm used to doing standard
so I went kind of are be heavy in the
first five six rounds I love it all
right I can't talk about fantasy anymore
Enrique you're on the Simpson left go
podcast you're a Raiders fan every does
um you can at you can ask anything you
can say anything right now cuz you're
the Grand Champion what would it be you
know what I just want to give a shout
out to everyone that participated you
know the Commissioner he did Meat Loaf
everyone didn't awesome job
Wow look at you what a good team player
you are man I know what what Raiders
topics do you want to talk about this is
your segment man you know what I'm from
Fresno
okay Derek Carr came to Fresno State
right so he's kind of a legend around
around here he's kind of everyone's
rooting for him obviously it was the
best I'm going to the Raiders it's kind
of been disappointing the last couple
years I'm hoping you know him working
with Gruden gives them some kind of
continuity and I'm hoping they can turn
it around
my question is you think car can make
leaps and bounds with good in this next
year I do I do I really I think first of
all you know let's not forget what Derek
Carr was two years ago let's not forget
that you know or I should say three
years ago let's
forget last year he played with you know
broken back parts and then this year he
had a deal with a whole new language
offense whole new culture of people and
different people around him new alliance
yeah new oline lots of different things
that he had to deal with so yeah I still
think Derek Carr has the ability to be a
really good quarterback in the NFL you
got young tackles you still got a decent
interior offensive line Gruden and
company and mike Mayock they're gonna
get some wide receivers to go along
there I do I have faith that the Raiders
can get this thing turned around dude
but you know that's gets good to hear
you know I've been a Raiders fan since I
was born so I've endured hardship yeah
so I'm gonna stick with them how old are
you I'm gonna be 35 next month yeah okay
all right 35 all right so you were alive
for some of the Super Bowl actually no
you were born in 83 I'm glad that the
SLM quart 84 you play that the s LFL
champion could legitimately run for
president he could run for president 3-5
yeah oh that's right that's right it's
good good to know we're gonna get you an
autograph from the big [ __ ] - since
that was your team name all right we'll
get we'll get you something from big
Phil and we'll get them to write you
something special on there dude wait did
you just have a birthday no my birthday
is next month oh because Nick got in my
ear and said that means he just had his
birthday it was bad information from our
audio I don't know I ran with it I got
excited I didn't know what to do wait so
I want also here what was the team
performance for the big [ __ ] on
Sunday like who had the big day like who
did you beat in the you know what were
the teams that were close to you there
with the final showdown you know what I
wasn't paying attention to everyone else
it was kind of difficult to see but you
know my spoken signal did it and who was
your big point taker this year who was
it who got it this week who was killed
like did Woods kill it this way I think
Williams had a big game week 16 was the
championship oh it was week 16 got you
got you got you okay all right Robbie
Anderson and he was a stud yeah
all right so Enrique I appreciate you so
much cuz you've been listening for so
long since 2014 is there has there been
any thing that you've disagreed with
Sims or me for all these years that
you've been like man I ever saw these
guys I'd really like to give them a
piece of my mind I love that question
you know what I my line of thinking kind
of aligns with you guys I think that's
why I can relate and I enjoy your
podcast so much I'm open to you know
suggestions and criticism but I'm also
you know I can be self-aware and I like
that you guys are South Scouty
each other and whatnot the only thing is
sometimes no let's go you got you got to
let them talk I knew I liked you
that's right but go ahead let go he's
correct he's kind of corrected it over
the last kind of six months or years old
he's comfortable everybody thank you
Enrique I appreciate that
hey you know one more thing Josh Ellen
grew up about 45 minutes from Fresno
gotcha fireball kid yep so you know
we're ready for him too
yeah don't worry we've adopted him here
already he's he's one of my favorites he
was my favorite guy coming out in the
draft he hasn't got enough respect for
even what he did the last few weeks up
in Buffalo but yeah he'd be one of those
guys that left Coe and I would both say
watch out for next year when they get a
little talent around him all right
Enrique yeah you're the man dude
we appreciate you thank you for your
support all the time congratulations on
being the Grand Champion in the
inaugural year of the SOL fantasy
championship I'm gonna give you a
podcast send-off so for Simms for
fencing for life go for Enrique what are
you gonna say Enrique you have to have a
tag line you gotta say bye to the fans
no let's do it again start from the top
hold on we're gonna come up with
something cool okay don't spell your
last name and say man at the end okay
though that's the only thing that's good
all right all right so oh let's just end
it here I guess we had a couple of
things in the rundown
music okay for Simms peace out homies
forfend Rick good evening on the lef koe
man and for Enrique one of the other
perfect
all right good [ __ ] Enrique holler at
you later brother you the man did all
right good bwaaa bye all right we're
back you killed music okay oh yes we got
to show this to sit real quick I was
where he was gonna go with that have you
seen what the Niners nation SP nation
website put together no so they put
together a clip of Kyle running routes
in the 2002 game against Houston
of you early season yeah and this just
made the rounds any comments on this
video yet you throw the ball to Kyle but
then I think major gets in there at the
end
it was cleanup time so yeah they bring
major in yeah man look at that look at
Kyle running a little skinny white ass
running around everywhere left go and I
were watching this and we saw right he
throw at the end yeah it was always no
that wouldn't have been this is my
senior year I'm wearing two so this is
not that wouldn't have been major that's
chance mock that's who that is chance
more chance mom with the rocket arm
chance has extremely talented from the
woodlands that Kyle had like five or six
catches IO was a phenomenal route runner
phenomenal like I'm not sugarcoating it
he had a few routes where Quinton jammer
was the number six pick in the NFL Draft
he knew and he had a cover Kyle he was
like damn these two routes cups he would
he was the master of the in cut he had
great hips Kyle so he could like be
running straight up field and almost
turn his hips like he was gonna run to
the right but then be able to stick his
foot in the ground and go left like he
was really gifted of the way he had
years of paying attention to ed
McCaffrey and Rod Smith you know what
else he brought to the team too he
brought the cross in the cleat which
I'll never forget I told you about that
yeah you know guys the cleats everyone
wants to wear their cleats really small
really tight I'm faster I'm gonna go
four four four nine nine nine to a four
four nine nine eight you know but you
cut a little hole where your big toe is
so you don't get turfed toe or jam your
toe all the time in these tight crease
it gives just a little room for the foot
and toe to move do you think he has the
receivers cut the X and their toes now
he's probably told about it you know the
shoes have gotten better I mean it
really has now I do believe he's got a
lot of these tapes that he shows his
players you know so I do yeah he likes
to slice his players tapes of him
running routes at Texas yeah I mean this
is a common thing in football like John
I saw clips of Jon Gruden when I was
playing for him playing a quarterback at
whatever crappy school he went just to
mix it up a little right there's just
things you throw a win to keep exactly
right I keep everybody fresh you can't
always put in a here's the film from
yesterday you know you get right you
liven up the room a little bit and go
like there's look at look at Josh in
high school I got some clips as coach
that mean just things like that right
what's his YouTube thing yeah so we
talked you talked about this a long time
ago but we had a fan on reddit ask if
this video is real and if not how it was
this fantasy file video right yeah made
all the throws some of them are not real
the best part about it is when I threw
to the stationary garbage cans I didn't
make one I didn't make one which is
embarrassing to say but when I I was a
master hitting the goal post and when I
was a master I almost killed our guy
driving the golfcart on that thing too
but man I probably had to throw like 10
throws there I made it in the garbage
can on the moving target like eight out
of the ten times you know but it was a
30 they're shooting the commercial I
think you were the first one I was these
guys could do anything right right and
and I did it and the first thing I did
was sort of the stationary garbage
things that were like 40 or 50 yards
away and I was like oh I'll hit one of
these in man I kept hitting a limp just
missing vova how long were you out there
for god I probably did it you know 45
minutes or so something like legit
throwing and I had no clue that was like
they asked me the NFL ask you to do
these type of things and they were like
you know fantasy and I'm like what
fantasy football what are you targeting
heaven
all I know is there was a field goal
kicker that made the commercial before
me where he could hit all the objects
and I was the second guy I saw the
commercials oh yeah that's cool I'll do
that who was the kicker I can't I want
to say was somebody down in Miami but
I'm not sure I can't even remember I am
oh wait the kicker for the fantasy it
was your boy that hit the the bells my
boy that hit the bells yeah nicely
Crosby oh why is that my boy I was just
making it okay yeah all right he did ask
about you though all right I'm go to the
dm's really quick I just want to see if
there's any questions here all right
this is Keaton Royce talking about the
Colts I just heard him say the Colts get
gashed in the run game I thought it let
me know that they didn't give up a 100
yard rusher all year and they went up
against Zeke Barclay Lamar Miller
Derrick Henry Joe Mixon a giant yeah
zero 100-yard rushing yeah I knew that
already I knew that I said that on TV
too so I can attest to that I I said it
on Sunday Night Football last week
I understand that you know Ezekiel a it
wouldn't ran for a hundred and fifty if
they didn't fall behind the holes were
big they would have ran it you just have
to be patient a lot of the times with
some of the good teams that have tried
to run the ball on them they either
don't have a pass game that the defense
respects or they've been fortunate
enough to play you know like I said in a
game like Dallas where they got up ahead
on the scoreboard and Dallas lost the
luxury of trying to be able to run the
football so I was very aware of that
when I said that I get that the Colts
what they try to do they play eight-man
fronts they know they're undersized and
they try to discourage you by running
inside by making a mess of things and
stunting and you've heard me say all
that stuff so they might bust through
the line of scrimmage and make a
five-yard tackle for a loss you've got
to stay with it because eventually
you're gonna hit them in the right stunt
and you're gonna gash one up the middle
for a huge game
all right last what I'm gonna do is
another self show yeah say quad didn't
run for a hundred but damn Eli Manning
threw for 300 so you gave up something
that was an issue in that game Oh Cho i
lucky self scout I think the fellows in
the pot are coming off a little soft on
Kirk I know this is a team sport trust
me but the reason Phil Simms deserves to
be the Hall of Fame is not because of
Peyton Manning stats but because when it
was
he found a way Kirk simply does not find
a way his record against 500-plus team
speaks for itself I'm a little confused
why you guys always want to protect him
yes he is interior offensive line issues
but so does to Shaun Watson every team
has issues but when you essentially odd
and don't make the playoffs Kirk 100%
deserve some blame my two cents peace
out homies Phil from Ottawa Canada yeah
I mean I get all that and he's not
deshaun Watson or in that class at all
so I don't put him there good stuff Oh
Joe you know those are all I hear you
all the way I don't think we're sitting
here trying to tell you that he's like
awesome right we're just trying to let
you know that he's not the number-one
issue there I think that's the big thing
we're trying to say and again I know
Curt a little bit you guys have seen me
interact with them it's not like we're
buddies or texting or calling or
anything like that but I just know him
through passing through the years I have
no vested interest in him either I'm
just trying to tell you that the
criticism was a little unfair is what
I'm trying to say there's a reason the
offensive coordinator was fired okay I
just watched the Bears film and let me
just tell you that I'm not sure three
people were open the whole game so and I
would also tell you that he didn't have
three seconds to throw the ball the
whole game too so again I'm not trying
to say he's great I'm just saying he's
good enough to win and you can win a
Super Bowl with Kirk Cousins but he is
not the issue of why or the number-one
issue why the Vikings didn't make the
playoffs that's all we're trying to say
right no you know what the number of
reason because the magic of the
Philadelphia Eagles is so strong through
the outro for sim peace out homies
forfend Rick good evening everybody
come on Dan he's sleeping back there any
day Nick and the lef koe seconds in the
betting segment man that's who he is
he's second in this batting second
there's a new champ in town
the champ is here the champ is here well
holler holler holler
holler holler holler holler at you later
I'm gonna beat him on the betting show
tomorrow I'm gonna retake my lead don't
worry about it here I come see you later
peace